er hätte jetzt eigentlich auch an der
Front gegen die Ukraine kämpfen müssen
unser Bild Russia Moderator Maxim
konikov er ist Offizier der russischen
Armee im März Flo er aus seiner Heimat
und arbeitet jetzt hier bei uns bei Bild
wir sind froh dass er bei uns ist weil
er bereit richtet uns von furchtbaren
Zuständen in der Armee
tausende russische Männer müssen in den
Krieg und er hätte eigentlich dabei sein
müssen Maxim konikov 38 Jahre alt
Journalist und Reserve Offizier der
russischen Armee in Moskau arbeitete er
für Eco moski einem der letzten
unabhängigen Medien in Russland Anfang
März flieht er aus seinem Heimatland
heute moderierte Journalist bei Wild
Rusher Russian Journalist just know
can't russischen Journalisten war es
verboten das Wort Krieg zu benutzen sie
gehen dafür ins Gefängnis einige meiner
Kollegen sind jetzt im Gefängnis
und ich wusste früher oder später wird
es eine Mobilmachung geben
ich bin aber gegen diesen Krieg und
wollte da nicht mitmachen
also entschied ich dass ich abhauen
musste aus Russland so schnell ich
konnte
2005 kam Maxim als Student zu Armee er
war gerade 21 Jahre alt für sein Studium
schlug er Messias Laufbahn ein die
Zustände in der russischen Armee schon
damals furchtbar der heraus
[Musik]
nur einmal pro Woche duschen ja
once awig kein Warmwasser keine Fenster
aber das eigentlich schlimmste war das
Essen und jetzt like a special
carpendant
Behälter aus den wir essen sollten die
waren voll von Exkrementen von Ratten
Jahre nicht benutzt kam aus den 50er
Jahren
Maxim hatte Glück er musste nicht lange
in der Armee bleiben konnte sein Studium
beenden als im Februar Russland den
Krieg gegen die Ukraine steht für ihn
fest er muss Weg raus aus Russland und
so kam es Maxim schaffte es raus aus
seinem Heimatland denn kurz darauf hätte
er das Land nicht mehr verlassen können
[Musik]